find dr. Jill wallet good afternoon
thank you how can I help you I got a
couple of questions for you okay
the first question is I have my partner
and she has lipstick ovary syndrome so
she's been like having trouble getting
pregnant because of the cyst in her
ovary so I was just wondering what I can
do to help with that okay how old is she
what is she way she weighs 150 pounds
and she's 35 years old okay she's still
cycling or is it irregular her cycle is
still cycling I believe her her cycles
irregular though okay all right did she
have any history asthma bronchitis same
respiratory problems any skin bums
eczema dermatitis psoriasis rosacea no
okay any bowel problems constipation
colitis also colitis Crohn's disease
diverticulitis appendicitis just
constipation constipation okay there's a
bingo okay
Charmaine what do you think's going on
here why does this gal have cystic ovary
syndrome he's probably got a gluten
intolerance okay and at 150 pounds would
you give her to support healthy female
hormone stuff and get her all the
nutrients necessary to support good
biochemistry all tissues including her
ovaries for those issues I would get her
on a healthy brain and her PEC and I
would add the woman's FX and the zero
fam
and the vitamin d3 okay what kind of
diet would you put her on
lots of eggs high fat diet let's egg
okay no gluten so maximize absorption
but she got some constipation there very
good and yeah she's Charmaine's exactly
right yes she should have maybe six
eight eggs a day they can be soft-boiled
soft oats they can go in the shake okay
if she's gonna have one of those weight
loss shakes I don't know how tall is she
she is 5 705 750 pounds of k97 but yeah
at least six dating today you know they
could go in our shakes they could go
Shawn scrambling butter they could be
soft pokes off well it's off yolks and
then give us a call every couple of
weeks we'll walk you through this but
with the 0fm and the woman's FX should
help jump-start things